deuxième partie de la voie est libre
effectivement avec nommé ruraux
dominique rey rien meredith saint
sauveur en puisaye jean-françois farenc
maire de bléneau vous êtes tous les deux
présidents de l'association des maires
ruraux de vos départements patrick
molinoz aux maires de venarey-les-laumes
trg fabien bazin maire socialiste de
l'ordre dans la nièvre fabien bazin
justement vous le disiez en ouverture de
cette émission je reçois farenc viens
d'en parler l'intérieur euro sont en
train de changer
concrètement parce que on se pose la
question il faut faire il faut faire
concrètement on fait quoi pour
aujourd'hui transformer un territoire
rural et au delà des discours est ce que
ça marche alors oui ça marche oui les
maires ruraux ont du talent oui
aujourd'hui à des initiatives qui
aboutit son terme de recherche de
professionnels de santé on en parle et
on en parlait en parler pendant les
informations en quelques semaines on a
récupéré sur ma commune un médecin
généraliste une dentiste de
kinésithérapeute de psychologues et
psychiatres et j'en ai un hôpital
c'est possible après l'autre défi
probablement à relever c'est comment
part à la reconquête des rues autrefois
commerçante qui sont aujourd'hui
dévitalisé et là encore il ya des outils
on sait que dans le nouveau contrat de
projet etat-région des crédits fléchés
comme l'écrit sectorielle de la région
viendront nous aider à démolir est à
reconstruire on sait qu'il faut créer le
chaînon manquant entre le maintien à
domicile et la maison de retraite où de
plus en plus et c'est malheureux on se
retrouve avec des gens qui sont atteints
de maladie d'alzheimer ou apparentée
donc est ce qu'on s'est inventé l'art et
la résidence seniors en milieu rural en
plein coeur de bourse un enjeu fort fort
mais s'il existe absolument c'est un
enjeu fondamental commune de
brinon-sur-beuvron 250 habitants est
chef lieu de canton ils ont aujourd'hui
un projet engagé est en train de
terminer les travaux de deux maisons de
ce type résidence seniors ils viennent
d'installer un traiteur il ya une petite
il ya une petite année ils sont en train
de reformater l'heureux leur supérette
250 habitants comment
on ne sait pas possible eh ben si c'est
possible on sait alors il faut faire
quoi il faut faire a transformé la
campagne en ville dont les urbains
rillettes non mais il faut travailler
beaucoup beaucoup à l'offre de services
moi je crois beaucoup à ça c'est à dire
que la ruralité
de demain c'est pas la réalité d'hier et
si le mouvement qui est un frémissement
quand même un de retour de la ville à la
campagne est ce que cette femme parce
qu'en réalité les chiffres masquent des
différences et quand même pas partout et
c'est pas massif c'est loin d'être
encore main sic il suffit de regarder
non mais vous pouvez regarder les
chiffres mêmes de lanières globalement
où la mode or c'est loin d'être massif y
met dix ans mais leur nation
mais c'est j'ai dit ça n'est pas massif
en tout cas l'offre de services si ça
vous fait plaisir de lire ses massifs
allez disons que ces massifs nous on ne
vit pas comme ça en coton au président
du département peut-être qu'il y
trouvera des solutions mais moi ce que
je crois que je crois que c'est sans
doute à différents troisième à la côte
d'ans sur cinq est d'accord je crois
sincèrement que le rural de demain n'est
pas leur grade hier et des gens qui ont
vécu en ville et qui éventuellement
reviennent vivre à la campagne d'abord
n'y travaillent pas forcément ils
peuvent être des gens qui se rendent sur
les grands centres où il ya pas mal
d'emplois en côte-d'or évidemment le
l'agglomération dijonnaise qui concentre
l'essentiel des emplois et ce sont des
gens qui naturellement vont vouloir de
plus en plus de services donc l'enjeu il
est clairement dans le commerce la
culture le sport et l offre en réalité à
une échelle effectivement plus modestes
mais quelque part de choses assez
semblable à ce qu'on peut trouver à ce
qu'on peut trouver en ville résidence
seniors on inaugure nous elle est
construite les gens sont dedans
on inaugure dans quelques dans quelques
semaines maison de santé les fêtes il
nous manquerait généraliste je me
permets de le redire j'en profite si
vous êtes général bien sûr on vient de
finir une salle de spectacle avec l'aide
de la région du département de l'état on
peut faire des choses et on en fait donc
il faut pas non plus qu'on soit dans une
espèce de de flagellation permanente il
y a de l'énergie et de la volonté en
zone rurale ce que l'on ne veut pas ce
que l'on ne veut pas c'est que le cadre
administratif ou légale et tous nos
initiatives et qui l'empêchent est
aujourd'hui puisqu'on était sur sa aux
espaces et sur la loi nôtre quand même
il ya des éléments qui inquiète parce
qu'il semble un peu contraignant voire
trop comprennent notamment cette
histoire suis désolé d'y revenir de
seuil qui est une réelle complexité mais
l'énergie dans les territoires ruraux
elle existe et nous sommes des
collectivités économe économe c'est pas
dans les territoires ruraux qu'on a
pléthore de fonctionnaires d'agents de
dépenses diverses et variées c'est pas
un territoire le rouge certainement pas
on fait beaucoup à mes yeux rien la
crise est aussi se transforme alors la
fusée se transformer un vrai changement
sociologique en puisaye et effectivement
nous sommes à 1h30 de paris et du coup
et nous avons beaucoup de gens qui
viennent s'installer en plus saint
sauveur nous avons guédelon à côté je
parle quelqu'un qui a les yeux sur sa
communauté de communes
nous avons beaucoup d'artistes également
qui viennent s'installer et je pense que
c'est une autre forme de développement
qu'il faut qu'on recherche en s'appuyant
sur les talents qui arrive comment on
fait vivre les artistes avec les
agriculteurs les gens qui vivaient là
avant parce que ça on l'a pas dit c'est
très joli coup que vos transformation
mais les ruraux les vrais ruraux e s qui
s'y retrouvent dans ce que vous faites
de vos villages alors bien sûr bien sûr
les ruraux s'y retrouve les ruraux
accompagne parce que quand vous parlez
de l'agriculteur l'agriculteur à une
femme qui souvent tient un commerce et
qui se retrouve parfaitement en avoir
toutes ces nouveaux habitants qu'ils
puissent fréquenter son commerce donc
oui bien sûr les ruraux s'y retrouve et
de toute façon nos conseils municipaux
sont composées de gens qui sont dans la
ville et qui représente la pluralité de
ses habitants donc non au contraire je
pense que tout le monde s'y retrouve les
ruraux s'y retrouve d'avoir quelqu'un
qui arrive de région parisienne et qui
reprend le café tout le monde et qui va
reprendre qui va pouvoir acheter ses
cigarettes parce qu'ils fument aussi non
tout le monde se retrouve d'avoir c'est
cette nouvelle population est en fait on
se rend compte que nous sommes puisque
moi-même je suis une nouvelle rural uneo
rural comme on dit je n'habitais pas là
à temps plein je suis venu m'installer
installé mon bureau à saint sauveur et
puis et puis voilà j'ai été adopté par
les gens de saint sauveur et et j'en
suis aujourd'hui mère est très heureuse
de l'être parce que c'est une ville qui
effectivement vie contrairement à ce
qu'on peut dire j'ai encore vu quelque
chose sur facebook ce matin qui parlait
de tj et des animations qui s'y
trouvaient nos communes vivent et
justement c'est pour ça qu'il faut les
garder il faut c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aussi garder leur talent parce que nous
nous connaissons nous travaillons
ensemble ce soir je n'ai je ne ferai pas
à paris pour voir le match mais je serai
sur la place de saint sauveur pour le
voir parce qu'on a un écran géant parce
qu'on va faire des merguez parce qu'on
sera tous sur la place pour regarder ce
qu'est ce que c'est compris vu de paris
sa moi j'ai noté danger noté dans un
nouveau papier c'est jany siméon dans la
nièvre il parlait de la main je retrouve
plus le texte la main masquer des
énarques balle à la main invisible des
énarques c'est du flan alors est-ce que
c'est du fantasme ou non ou est-ce que
aujourd'hui les gens ont envie d'avoir
été avec les énarques les machins les
trucs c'est ici à des gens à dénoncer
l'éventuelle ans et bercy mais c'est
clair que l'enjeu pour nous tous c'est
effectivement de définir aujourd'hui une
politique publique de la ruralité qui
n'existent pas les seules propositions
qui existe c'est ce qu'ont fait les
choses sur lesquelles on allait
travailler en avait appelé ça à l'époque
le bouclier vous avez travaillé sur le
monde et un bouclier de radis 0t j'ai
les ruraux dans la slovaquie disait des
choses assez simples qui disait en gros
très haut débit partout et pour tous
donc plan national très haut débit qui
disait on aurait environ leppard locales
ont là l'une des difficultés actuelles
de la de la ruralité c'est que sur les
80 millions d'encours dans une agence
d'une ville de 1500 et 2500 habitants
vous avez 20 millions qui sont
réinvestis sur place le reste va être
investi ailleurs comment par la loi on
permet à ce que les moyens des gens qui
vivent les territoires soient réinvestis
chez eux la même manière est ce qu'on
est capable de définir aujourd'hui le
modèle économique de la maison de la
presse du salon de coiffure du garage
automobile en zone rurale c'est ça le
boulot des élus aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on arrive à sortir ce modèle là parce
que il faut tout réinventer on est à là
encore une fois à la fin d'une histoire
c'est celle de l'exode rural qui a duré
très longtemps donc on a on l'a bien en
tête et aujourd'hui il faut qu'on gère
l'exode urbain et qu'on gère de manière
intelligente et en même temps fabien
bazin moi je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable il n'y a pas eu de loi sous le
gouvernement sarkozy sur leur ruralité
d'accord votre bouclier rural il
n'apparaît pas plus dans une loi de la
gauche aujourd'hui à figer le nom mais
on mais on a obtenu quand même un
certain nombre de choses scolarisation
des enfants de moins de 3 ans
interdiction d'être à plus de 30 minutes
dana d'un accueil d'un accueil d'urgence
il ya des choses qui ont bougé bon il ya
beaucoup à faire c'est évident mais si
on me propose rien et intérêts si on
prend pas le temps au fond de ce débat
et de la réflexion sur ce qu'on veut ce
qu'on demande ce que n'ont pas vraiment
fait les maires ruraux parce qu'on était
plutôt à défendre l'élevage lutter
contre la fermeture de l'école mais un
bureau de poste et là on n'a jamais pris
le temps de poser nos propositions
aujourd'hui elles existent ça s'appelle
bouclier rural savez une nouvelle
ruralité aussi un sujet qui a été pris
on sait la nièvre qui a vanté sa tombe
la mise tant mieux ça aurait été les
autres seront été très bien aussi pense
qu'on peut se retrouver autour de ça et
il faut effectivement plaider la cause
d'une ruralité moderne qui totalement le
travail de la république cité vous avez
essayé d'élaborer l'idée d'un modèle
d'un modèle de village du futur assassin
en vous après le bouclier rural qui
étaient des mesures nationales
aujourd'hui ce qu'on propose c'est de
dire on peut inventer le village du
futur et dans le village du futur on
invente des nouveaux métiers par exemple
on a d urbanisme non il faut des
ruralistes il faut des gens spécifique
sur la gestion de l'habitat rural on a
des bénévoles c'est très bien on a
beaucoup mais il faut aussi des
bénévoles east ces gens qui forment les
futurs responsables d'associations parce
qu'ils ont cette expérience là donc il
faut qu'on fasse appel à des nouveaux
métiers des gens qui s'appellent des
designers de services par exemple qui
vous met en mots et en compréhension les
politiques publiques de soirée nos
concitoyens un des sujets un des
problèmes c'est le qu est-ce qu le qui
fait quoi ils comprennent pas ce sera la
meilleure volonté aussi puisqu'on est
dans dans dans les sig contre le cmq le
c'est moi qui c'est ça qui nous tue à
dire que au fond nous concitoyens que ce
soit la commune l'intercommunalité le
département l'état la région qui fasse
peu importe ce qu'ils demandent c'est
que ce service soit rendue mais que
services soient données délivrées et
qu'ils comprennent pourquoi il ya de la
fiscalité et à quoi elle sert bon bah ça
c'est le travail aujourd'hui des moeurs
vous aimez faux pas ils ont totalement
dans le faux pas être totalement dans la
démagogie non plus le semo dit je veux
bien et il est vrai que les concitoyens
bon ils veulent le résultat peu importe
comment ça arrive mais nous on sait bien
que pour arriver au résultat il faut une
architecture qu est ce qu il faut une
année ce qui fait que qui le permettent
nous reste les bouts de rien une minute
45 10 aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya eu un
point juste que la demande et la
question vous aviez posé pendant qu'on
n'a pas répondu c'était est ce que on
comprend à paris ce qu'ils
pensent que non globalement c'est
compliqué et globalement ils ont du mal
il ya un enjeu immédiat dans l'est dans
les semaines dans les mois qui vient qui
viennent c'est celui de la grande région
des grandes régions où il faudra que les
grandes régions est le sens des
territoires
parce que si elle plus puisque la région
vont avec le risque qu'ils aient la doxa
dans le rétro des grandes régions pour
l'état qui comprennent pas comment ces
territoires et s'est parlé de risques
par les opportunités ne soyons pas on va
inventer la loi il faut objectiver le
système mais c'est vrai que là bas
les fusions et s'est fait manger et les
collectivités n'ont jamais fait la
compétitivité ça c'est un conte pour les
enfants ce sont des outils encore une
fois
soit bien on répondre à votre question
c'est vrai qu'on a on a l'impression que
le niveau parisien arrive plus
facilement à inventer ce que doivent
être les métropoles gens connaissent mal
qu'on allait donner c'est très bien
ainsi 100 millions d'euros je prends à
marseille et que par contre l'invention
de la nouvelle ruralité c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué et on a du mal à y
arriver alors on fait plein de choses à
moi j'ai entendu parlé mettent à l'heure
de jeu centre de télétravail je dois
arrêter je puisse vous arriver c'est la
fin d'émission
c'est mal mais c'est comme ça
merci à tous les quatre merci à tous les
cadres d'être venus débattre sur ce
sujet je rappelle juste ce soir 20
heures 20 en direct du stade de france
juste avant la finale de la coupe de
france de foot entre temps vous avez le
droit de sortir avant de regarder la
télé bon week-end au revoir et à bientôt